um
some props now courtesy of the points
bet sportsbook will either daniel jones
or carson wench reach 300 yards passing
chris well if i'm gonna go with one i'm
gonna go with carson wentz i am i don't
think it'll be easy you know the giants
defense it's well coached
it really is and because they don't have
to like
you know
they have they're so big up front with
some of their big guys they they don't
have to
add extra people into helping the run
game and then of course the eagles
aren't a very good running team in
general you know
uh they can be tricky that way but just
the eagles they're just gonna keep
throwing it and i don't think the giants
are talented enough in the back end to
where if you're gonna make me pick one
or the other yeah i'm picking uh carson
wentz and the philadelphia eagles daniel
jones and the offensive side of the ball
for the giants you know there's just
there's issues across the board and
really i just feel like if you kind of
stop darius slayton
then you're going to be in a good spot
playing against the giants
do you think either of these guys really
is in a spot where
the team is thinking
should we look somewhere else for 2021 i
think maybe for jones i still think the
eagles are so invested in wentz yeah
giving him the money they picked him
over nick foles i feel like they need to
keep doubling down on wentz for a few
more years to come i just really wonder
about daniel jones especially if there
would be a gm change if there's a gm
change all bets are off for the new york
giants but i just you know we haven't
seen the growth and development i don't
know how much of that to put on him yeah
versus the circumstance right you don't
have saquon barkley when you don't have
a great offensive line what do we expect
from this guy exactly right to me it's
more the circumstance is he perfect no
but you know decision maker and thrower
he's really damn good yes still has a
little bit of a fumbling thing that's
got to be fixed there's no doubt about
that but it's better this year than last
year but man yeah you know two years two
different offenses not a lot of support
at the wide receiver position no run
game to speak of for this first two
years his career and
i think arguably
you know some of the worst pass
protection and stuff that we've seen in
football over the last two years have
been in the new york giants so
i'm a believer in daniel jones still you
know it's another case here of like
there's the team
is so bad you can't really see how good
he is uh and then with your carson wentz
i mean it's a valid question the
perception is you know it's all to me
messed up because of the nick foles and
the super bowl thing and all that but i
would sit here and argue and go i carson
wentz is the best player on the eagles i
mean he's the best player he's the
reason it was a game last week you know
and i know people will say well he had a
turnover into things like yeah well he's
got to do everything i mean he's got to
do it all there's no
you know top tier receiver top tier
running back nothing it's all on carson
wentz to make plays and the offense
isn't like that creatively good to where
it's just like oh people are flying wide
open and he's missing them that not at
all all right back to the odds for
tonight and here's one that's a special
custom bet that points bet made for us
using the name a bet feature which
quarterback will have more turnovers
tonight daniel jones or carson wentz uh
i'm gonna go with daniel jones i mean
both have a little bit of a you know
turnover issue both have a little bit of
the like try to do too much at times
type of you know disease or whatever for
lack of a better phrase there there but
i think i will go with with daniel jones
you know again i think this eagles
defense is is pretty damn good they're
pretty good up front the giants don't
have great weapons on the outside i do
think the eagles will be able to man
them up you know darius slay he'll be
matched up with slayton i would expect
uh yeah and no run game in the past pro
i'm gonna go with daniel jones has more
turnovers
yeah and look he's got the history of
more turnovers but i agree with you
carson once at times tries to do too
much yeah maybe this is one of those
nights coming off of that game against
the ravens a much better defense than
the giants yeah maybe maybe it's given
the eagles
i know
when when you lose a game
that you should have won you fall into
that one loss can become two especially
on a short week when you almost win a
game that you were supposed to lose
that give you a nice little kick in the
butt that may make you want to turn it
around and play on thursday night and go
out and show what you can do against a
team that is not nearly as good as the
team you almost beat chris i agree with
that mike i do yeah there there was i
think uh that is not like a crushing
defeat that is more of a hey look we
messed some things up and we still had a
chance to tie the football game you know
on the last play there's a silver lining
they kind of say that about the last two
weeks they're going to be able to look
at it and go wait most people say the
steelers and the ravens are two of the
three best teams in football we were
there toe-to-toe with them so i think
those are the things and then the big
thing is for carson wentz he's going to
take a big breath tonight and go man
this giants defense isn't the ravens or
steelers this is this is easier and i
would imagine like we've seen from him
the last few years and night games
against the giants he's gonna have some
highlight type plays two years ago it
was a thursday night game in new york
last year he had that amazing comeback
right in philly we thought eli was going
to get one more win they went into i
think what 17 nothing at halftime
something like that he brought him back
i think you'll see some special plays
from wentz tonight
and this is one of the basic realities
of life in the nfl right now is we see a
proliferation of competent quarterbacks
and there are plenty of great
quarterbacks out there somebody's gotta
lose games every week yeah that's right
in a week with no buys you're gonna have
16 winners and 16 losers and and
sometimes two of the best quarterbacks
are playing each other that's just the
way it works you're going to lose games
carson wentz doesn't have the help
around him right now guys are injured
he's going to lose some games that
doesn't mean he's not a franchise
quarterback all right more rushing yards
tonight devante freeman
who a lot of people think could maybe
step up and fill this void now that
saquon barkley's been out for several
weeks or boston scott i'm gonna go
boston neither team is a great running
team but the eagles are clearly the
better running team compared to the
giants
i mean devonte freeman has been a nice
little addition he's had some moments
but
you know the one thing the eagles seem
to pop a run every week whereas it's
average it's average and then it's you
know a big one and then of course
there's the you know the other thing
that's hard with defending the eagles is
carson wentz he'll keep the ball and do
that stuff too that gives him a little
advantage there i'm just going to have
more faith in the doug peterson run game
in o-line compared to the giants and
i'll go with boston scott
i'll agree with you there let's move on
to more receiving yards darius slaten to
the giants or travis fulgum of the
eagles a guy who's really come on and i
know tony dungy is a big fan of his uh
he always seems to flash whenever
whenever tony gives him some praise and
he's been flashing a lot lately this
will be close this will be closed darius
slayton is some player he really is and
he is a like he's a mismatch nightmare
kind of he's not the kind of guy like
you can feel comfortable about like
one-on-one coverage and man the eagles
have been you know they know how to feed
people and they've been getting the ball
to travis fulgum
i i again
i just the way the eagles feature people
like that it with you know whether some
weeks it's hurts or whatever else i'm
gonna go with travis falgon because i
just think he's earned the trust of doug
peterson and wentz i don't feel as
confident about this one because i do
think there might be whoa it's
man-to-man bump and run on darius
slayton and daniel jones hits a few big
passes to him but i guess if yeah i'm
gonna go with travis falcon i am so last
prop bet more touchdowns tonight the
giants are the eagles well i mean i'm
picking the eagles to win the game i'm
just you know the cat's out of the bag
there and i'm going to pick the e hey
the broncos the broncos one with no
touchdown oh you're right you're right
well i'm still going to go with more
touchdowns from the eagles i am
yeah yeah i am and and you know i'm
getting really gun shy about our our
picks because i always go with my gut i
don't know that my gut is is doing me
any favors this year though i mean we're
gonna pick the eagles to win and if we
were doing this on football night in
america if we had giants eagles it would
be equals equals eagles all the way
across the board and then the giants
would win and they'd stick it in our
faces through their social media pages
because god forbid god forbid we make
our predictions based upon the past
performance of the team that justifies
being picked again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports